please help me welcome mr. Ben Shapiro
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm glad to see that you made the trek
all the way out to the cow campus that's
exciting I said I did see the other
livestock on the way here I also want to
thank the police officers who are
protecting this event apparently there
are a hundred police officers that were
necessary to protect you guys and to
protect me so that I can say basically
conservative things and all of this
because of the overkill that is
necessary on the university level thanks
to the idiocy of so many of the leftist
protesters who threaten violence and
threaten trouble I will say that some of
the protesters outside good for them I
mean it does take some at least they're
putting their their money where their
mouth is this cold outside so good for
them for at least for at least going out
there I think it's not that cold out
here right for you guys so just just for
me I'm from California whatever okay so
I'm I'm a wimp all right so I am glad
that they're not in proximity to
actually shut down the rail lines which
was supposedly the reason why we were
all forced to come all the way out here
now the statement from the university
president on why we are all out here as
opposed to on the main campus is just
absurd his statement suggested quote the
university hosts a wide variety of
events welcoming tens of thousands of
people to campus each and every day and
yet magically they somehow couldn't fit
got a thousand of us on the main campus
they had to shuttle us all the way over
here since we strive to meet the unique
needs for each and every event and the
events scheduled for later this month is
no different when working to accommodate
a venue request our top priority is and
will always be the safety and security
of our university community and with
that in mind the university works with
organizers to determine a location that
meets everyone's needs to the best of
our ability well it didn't really meet
the needs of the several hundred people
who are on the wait list who wish they
could come but they could not because
the venue is simply too small they said
this has nothing to do with ideological
discrimination which comes surprise
considering the number of mainstream
leftist speakers who have come to this
campus few of whom have actually been
sent all the way out here now I also
appreciate that the University of
Minnesota greenlit an event protesting
white supremacy in the age of Trump on
the main campus and anti-racist teachin
which is super exciting I guess this is
done in opposition to this event it's
really exciting since I'm not alike
supremacist you may notice from the
Jewish headgear that I constantly wear
was actually the top target of
anti-semitism on the internet in 2016
among among journalists and I didn't
vote for Trump so well done guys he
really hit you were spot on on that
entire description white supremacy in
the age of Trump every single word
except for in the and of is wrong okay
so tonight you know before I go any
further I do have one further note on
University of Minnesota apparently you
guys are supposed to have some sort of
BDS vote in the next few days for those
who don't know boycott divestment
sanctions which is a program to get the
university to divest from all companies
that do business with the State of
Israel that's an anti-semite oh that's
an anti-semitic program that program is
designed to strike at the heart of the
State of Israel the Jewish state the
only reason anybody's even considering
it is because it is the Jewish state I
am not aware of any movement on the
campus here for divestment from Iran for
a vestment from Afghanistan for
divestment from Indonesia from an
investment from Saudi Arabia from
foreign investment from Jordan from
divestment from Egypt I'm not aware of
any of those all places with egregious
human rights records but Israel is a
different story because of course it's
filled with Jews
so before anyone both for BDS they
should just understand exactly what it
is that they are doing they are
full-scale endorsing anti-semitism on a
grand scale all right so now let's get
to the main topic so today's topic is
capitalism in the First Amendment and
unfortunately capitalism has gotten a
really bad rap particularly among people
of our generation I'm barely still of
your generation right so I'm gonna hold
on to that that signifier as long as I
possibly can to many young Americans
don't know anything about capitalism
they don't know why it's good they think
socialism is good there's a Harvard
Institute of Politics poll in spring
2016 and it found that Bernie Sanders
that loon bag was the only major
candidate with a net positive rating
among 18 to 29 year olds 54% pavéd
viewed him favorably compared with just
31% who viewed him unfavorably and now
they're making the argument we should
lower the voting age to 16 I can't see
how that goes wrong the same poll showed
that only 42% of young Americans
supported capitalism 33% said they
supported socialism as in full-scale
socialism like one in three young
Americans supports full-scale socialism
fully 50% of all democratic voters said
they favored socialism over capitalism
one in two that's probably because young
people are too young too
member when socialist nations like the
USSR actually threaten nuclear
destruction when they murdered tens of
millions of people I mean there still
are some Soviet there's still some
Soviet style dictatorships right the
Communist Chinese are still imprisoning
millions and billions of people under
repressive harsh rule North Korea
obviously is still a communist paradise
where people are shipped off to gulag
but the idea of socialism has become
very popular among young people and the
reason that it's become popular among
young people is because they've been
told that it is moral not that it works
not that it's great but that it's moral
it's fair and we all like things that
are fair I've we're in a room and
somebody has more money and somebody has
lost money wouldn't it be more fair if
we just pulled the money and then we
split it up evenly among the
participants you know just like the
cookies in kindergarten
except of course that's not the way the
world works and that's not actually
moral because in a free country wealth
and the capacity to gain it is largely
contingent on the decisions that you
make it doesn't just fall upon you most
wealth in the United States is not
inherited most well from the United
States is created over the course of
lifetimes by people who engage in
economic activity and commerce
capitalism is good because capitalism is
freedom
socialism is bad because socialism is
tyranny not it's an aspect of tyranny
socialism itself is tyranny the
statement of socialism is that your
labor is owed to the society the notion
of socialism is that you do not own your
own freedom you do not own your own time
you do not own your own labor you do not
own your own work using not on the
products of your own work the basic
notion of capitalism is you own all of
those things and now you have to engage
in free exchange with someone else who
does not owe you anything if you want to
thrive if you want to succeed you are
going to have to make something somebody
else wants people think capitalism is
selfishness
now socialism is selfishness the notion
that I have to somehow supply you the
money so you can sit in your basement
and paint with watercolors socialism the
idea that I'm supposed to fulfill all
your dreams by paying you for something
I don't want and have no need for but
capitalism is precisely the opposite we
all do stuff in our daily jobs that we
don't like why because there's a group
for it who want to consume it how many
people love their daily job every day
I'm lucky I get to go to a job that I
really enjoy every day but a lot of
people don't and you know why they do it
they do it because they understand that
in a free society they are going to have
to produce something
that is not entertaining and interesting
only to them if my podcast had one
listener I would have to quit podcasting
and if your if whatever business you go
into has no customers your business will
go out of business as I'm fond of saying
capitalism is forced altruism it forces
you to do something that somebody else
wants if you want to live
socialism is forest altruism in a
different way it's forcing your altruism
to me right capitalism is about I have
to be forced to do something good for
you in order for me to live and
socialism is about the idea that I have
to be forced to do something for you so
that you can live that's not the same
thing at all
capitalism also happens to be the most
efficient system for the distribution of
wealth from the history of mankind it is
the greatest capital it is the greatest
engine for growth in the history of
mankind it is the single greatest force
for the empowerment of individual human
beings in the history of mankind so why
is it unpopular after all this is said
it's unpopular because it's very easy to
demagogue capitalism any policy that has
diffused costs and concentrated benefits
is a popular policy by Nature any policy
that is diffused costs and concentrated
benefits is going to be popular so
subsidies for example to farmers in Iowa
those are popular because farmers in
Iowa get a big chunk of cash and you
only lost one cents off your paycheck so
you didn't even see it you can even
notice it well socialism is sort of the
same idea if you don't notice the money
coming off your paycheck then you're not
going to notice that that one person is
getting a bunch of money so that person
benefits and that person feels good
about the benefits they just received
but you don't even notice the money
coming off except that in a socialist
system you have to take so much money
off the top that everybody notices of
course now socialism in and of itself as
I say is tyrannical it is evil socialism
violates at least three of the Ten
Commandments and it puts government
before God it says that theft is fine
theft is no longer a problem so long as
you and your friends vote for it and of
course petty jealousy is something that
is necessary it's good to be jealous
workers of the world must unite not
because they're necessarily being
grinded down by the Bootheel of
capitalism but simply because they are
jealous of the achievements of others so
much of America's discussion right now
but income inequality is not about the
suffering poor so much of it is about
the so-called thriving rich the 1% at
the top is about tearing down the people
who succeed not about empowering the
people who are failing if we were really
talking about helping
who are we be talking about helping the
poor not income inequality income
inequality itself does nothing that
discussion does nothing to help the poor
what we have to talk about is ways that
we can help people who are poor rise out
of current circumstance through better
decision-making and better opportunity
how about socialism in Europe you know
well well people so people have who are
defenders of socialism and said okay
well you know you guys always mention
Cuba you always mention North Korea you
always mentioned the USSR you always
mention China but well they say China is
growing
China's growing because they loosened up
their economy and now it's basically
state capitalism but then they say well
what about the socialistic countries of
Europe so this is Bernie Sanders is play
and what about Denmark what about
Switzerland what about Sweden those are
not socialist countries
those are capitalist countries with a
high taxes system okay that's not the
same thing a socialist country his
government owns the means of production
it is about heavy regulation of all
parts of the economy Denmark is actually
a better climate to do business than the
United States is according to the
Heritage Foundation significantly better
there's a lot of foreign investment in
Denmark
what makes Denmark a so-called socialist
countries the fact that it has 60
percent tax rates that's also the reason
their economy stagnated so much that he
just had to radically cut their tax
rates the same thing is true in Sweden
Sweden gained riches only after
embracing capitalism in the mid 19th
century from set in 1975 to 1993 when
they put in place all of these social
programs with high levels of spending
and high levels of Taxation the country
dropped from fourth in the world wealth
linkit ranking to fourteenth Swedish
scholar Nima sand onji called the
country's embrace of redistribution ISM
a colossal failure which is why they had
to liberalize their markets again ok
again back to income inequality for a
second what about this idea that
socialism Pure's the evils of income
inequality first of all every country on
earth has some level of income
inequality in fact some of the places
with the least income inequality are
also some of the poorest places on earth
there are places where everybody is
destitute if you go over to certain
countries in Africa or Asia everyone is
poor and there's no income inequality
does that mean that these are great
places to live no means these are
horrible places to live because nobody
has any wealth America has high levels
of income inequality but our poor are
richer than everybody else is poor which
is the thing that matters in the United
States even the poor people are rich by
global standards according to Pew
Research quote almost nine and ten
Americans had a standard of living that
was above the global
income standard and by the way the
notion that the upper-middle club that
the middle class has been just taking it
on the chin in the past few decades in
the United States this is not true the
upper middle class has been picking up
all the people who used to be in the
middle class it's not that the middle
class devolved into poverty it's at the
middle class split and most of the
middle class became upper middle class
the upper middle class was just twelve
percent of Americans in 1979 as of 2014
thirty percent of Americans were now
upper middle class and it's also worth
noting that all of our schemes to end
income inequality have been an enormous
fail we've spent 22 trillion dollars in
the war on poverty to no avail we spend
$30,000 per year on poor non-elderly
families and that's paid for by the rich
for all let's talk about income
inequality and the rich not paying their
fair share the rich are paying pretty
much everything statistically speaking
people who are high earners in this
country are paying virtually all net
cost that the federal government incurs
according to the CBO report on
distribution of taxes in 2013 the top 1%
of households paid thirty four percent
of their income to federal taxes the
middle 20% paid just 13 percent
according to the American Enterprise
Institute the highest income quintile is
financing ninety-six percent of the
entire system of transfer payments to
the bottom sixty percent and funding the
functioning of the federal government as
well we actually have the most
progressive tax system among all osed 24
countries for I'll talk about how all
the rich people are getting rich in the
United States and the poor people are
getting poorer we have the most
progressive tax system in all of the
Ocoee CD an income mobility has not
declined this is another myth that's
pushed out there that if you're poor you
can never become rich in the United
States this is not true at all when
people talk about the people in the 1%
getting richer they forget you will be
in the 1% one day and you may not be in
the 1% one day I've been not in the 1%
I've been in the 1% I assume at some
point in the future I won't be in the 1%
by income earning anymore if people move
in and out of percentiles of income it's
not the same person it's not that you
were born into the 1% and then you
stayed in the 1% your entire life just
getting more wealthy in fact
statistically speaking if you were in
the 1% there's a pretty good shot that
you're gonna regress to the mean for
those who are in the top 1% in 1996 and
we're not talking about than 1% bracket
we're talking bout the actual people in
the 1% in 1996 by 2005 their income had
decreased on average by 26% and
income ability works the other way too
according to Thomas solo a University of
Michigan study showed most of the
working people who were in the bottom
20% of income earners in 1975 were also
in the top 40% at some point by 1994 and
by 1991 only 5% of those in the bottom
quintile in 1975 were still there in
1991 29% of them were now in the top
quintile that makes a lot of sense right
now there are a lot of people in this
room who are in the bottom or middle
income quintile because you're in
college you're not making money in ten
years you will be making money
presumably and when that happens you
will have moved up in the world as you
age you gain more wealth this is why
your grandmother owns a house but you
presumably do not yet okay this will
happen to all of you so don't pay
attention to the fall statistics that
are being put out there about how in
America it's impossible to get ahead
that's just not true also worth noting
all the talk about the United States
sucking up all the wealth of the world
it is because of a capitalist global
system that has become more and more
prominent free markets that have become
more and more prominent that literally
half the world has been lifted out of
abject poverty since 1980 that's because
of the force and power of the US free
market economy that has been driving all
of that growth the countries by the way
that are poor in in the world those
countries are not the ones that are that
are being hurt by free trade they're the
ones that aren't even participating in
free trade two-thirds of the global poor
on planet Earth
live in just five countries India China
Nigeria Bangladesh and Congo according
to the Heritage Foundation index of
economic freedom every single one of
those countries ranks 128 or below in
terms of free markets this is not a
coincidence freer markets means more
wealth freer markets mean more growth
okay now onto the second issue we're
going to talk about and that of course
is free speech and this one obviously
has become a more pressing concern
than even the capitalism conversation
simply because of all the hubbub
surrounding events like this one we've
been told that we have to hold events
like this one and places far away from
main campuses because we might make
someone feel uncomfortable and if those
people feel uncomfortable then they get
to exercise the hecklers veto and we
have to move the entire event away from
fora that hosts 1,500 people and into
smaller venues that host 500 people and
we have to put 300 people on the wait
list because obviously we wouldn't want
to offend anyone those people outside
they're the people in the right the
people protesting again it's fine for
them to approach
but the people who are either protesting
or who are threatening and necessitated
the taxpayer dollar is going toward the
use of 100 police officers tonight
those people are the problem you are not
the problem I am NOT the problem the
people who are creating the threats that
required the spending of tens if not
hundreds of thousands of dollars to hold
events like this one those people are
the problem and unfortunately their
philosophy is a growing one the idea
that if we say stuff that's offensive
this is a form of violence and therefore
violence can be used in response and
that's why we need to bring in police
officers in order to protect all of this
this is just an aspect of identity
politics how is it that when I say
something this is an aspect of violence
because I'm attacking someone's identity
don't you see it's not just that I'm
saying something with what you disagree
it's that I'm attacking your identity so
when I say socialism is stupid and
capitalism is good there are some people
who feel offended by this when I suggest
that in a free country you should be
able to rise as an individual if you
just do some simple things if you make
some simple good decisions then this is
seen as offensive by certain people to
their identities if I say that white
privilege is not a thing if I say that
just because you were born white in the
United States does not mean that you are
bound to succeed and that if you were
born black in the United States that you
were bound to fail this is seen as an
attack on identity now what makes any of
this an attack on identity the victim
mentality that purports to suggest that
every failure you have is due to the
color of your skin or the area in which
you were born or the religion that you
practice all of this is nonsense but
when I say that it makes people feel bad
it makes people feel bad because a lot
easier to blame everybody else for your
problems than it is to take
responsibility for your own problems now
this is not to say there's no such thing
as discrimination of course there is
it's not to say there aren't people who
are suffering from racism or bigotry of
course there are people who are
suffering from those things but we are
all on their side there's not a person
in this room I would imagine who sees a
racist incident a clearly racist
incident and doesn't feel terrible about
it and doesn't seek to help I don't know
a lot of people out there in the United
States who are looking around going look
at that terrible racist incident so
happy that happened and if they are
they're not coming to my speeches those
aren't the people who are showing up and
listening to what I have to say those
are the people who aren't going and
listening to the all right maybe those
are some of the people who are listening
to members of the radical left those
aren't people
who are showing up to mainstream
conservative speeches but again if you
challenge the notion that we live in a
victim first culture if you challenge
the notion that in a free country you
can succeed then this is bound to make
people feel really bad and so white
privilege microaggressions trigger
warnings this has become the order of
the day on college campuses and the way
this works is that we now judge you not
by the by the contents of your character
but by the color of your skin we are
supposed to discern whether your view is
good or bad not by what you have to say
but simply by who you are so because we
have a white privileged country a
country filled with privileged white
people built by white people for white
people because of all of that if you are
a white person then you have to take a
ticket and go to the back of the line
when it comes to the views that you get
to express or you have to shut up
entirely now never mind that there are
minority groups in the United States who
are making a lot more money on a per
capita basis then white people are in
the United States I choose where
minority group in the United States are
still a minority group in the United
States now for purposes of the census
they've been considered white but for a
long time they were barred from country
clubs for example Jews on average earn
more than the average white person does
in the United States if you count them
as a separate census group same thing is
true for Asian Americans Asian Americans
have the single greatest income on a
family level of any group in the United
States is that because of Asian
privilege is that because of Jewish
privilege in the United States or is
that because there are a lot of people
in these particular subgroups who work
really hard and have a culture that
pushes working really hard that has
nothing to do with race that has
everything to do with the decisions that
are made by parents to raise their
children in a particular way with a
particular viewpoint on hard work but
again white privilege has to be the
order of the day so that people don't
feel bad about themselves well I'm here
to suggest that if you're failing in the
freest country in the world and you
can't point to actual evidence of
discrimination against you you should
feel bad about yourself because you've
done something wrong you've failed
you've made bad decisions maybe you're
not working hard enough now I'm not
saying that people who of course are
born with with problems you have people
who have mental illness people who have
physical disability people who are
obviously born behind the eight-ball in
terms of what they can achieve that's
something that's different but I'm
talking about the normal average
everyday American
of any race any color any creed if
you're failing in the United States
right now there's a really good shot
it's because you did something stupid
the reality is according to the
Brookings Institute which is a
left-leaning Institute I've cited the
stack many many times virtually everyone
in the United States who has done these
three things will never be permanently
poor get a job finish high school don't
have babies before you're married that's
it
you know those three things in the
United States you will not be
permanently poor as I've always said you
are capable of doing all of these three
things you're all here you're all in
college that means you finished high
school you're all capable of getting a
job I assume even poli-sci majors I know
I was one and you're all capable of not
having a baby until you're married as I
always say just don't put that thing
there without that other thing on it
it's not that difficult somehow people
for dozens of years have been avoiding
pregnancies that they didn't want so all
of this is to say that if we are going
to start shutting down free speech if
we're going to start throwing out
particular viewpoints because of the
identity of people this is a form of
tyranny and free speech matters because
if we don't have free speech then
minority viewpoints viewpoints that once
minority can never become majority one
of the great ironies of this whole
situation is that it's minority interest
groups that have been taking the lead on
shutting down free speech but if free
speech have been shut down in 1960 you
would not have gay rights you would not
have civil rights you would not have
women's rights all of these issues were
at one point minority issues now there
are majority issues what turns a
minority issue into a majority issue is
our capacity to debate it and reason
through it and have conversations about
it but now there are a bunch of folks
who want to shut that door who want to
say listen we've got the perfect society
we've got our utopia and we're dominant
politically and now everybody else has
to shut up that's not the way that this
works the way this works is we all get
to have a conversation together and if
you have a problem with that then you're
on American because this was the basis
of a free and open society the notion
that we could discuss with each other
that we weren't going to question each
other's motives first and foremost that
we were going to reason with one another
the whole basis of Republic is the idea
that we are rooted in reason I'm writing
a book right now on everything moving
from ancient philosophy to modern
philosophy it's a real page-turner and
the entire
the entire premise of Western
civilization is that freedom is
predicated on the idea that we can
discuss with one another without relying
on identity as the trump card once
identity becomes the trump card how the
hell are we gonna have a conversation
because all you do is just shout you
can't understand me I'm black and all I
do is shout you can't understand me I'm
Jewish
okay well then the conversation is over
and I guess we ought to just go get our
mallets and hit each other because
that's the only way that any of this is
going to get resolved that's not the way
things are supposed to work
unfortunately we're seeing it play out
that way in virtually every political
debate the gun debate just being the
most obvious lately folks suggesting
both people who are witnesses to the
shooting down in parklands and members
of the media suggesting that if you
disagree with them then it's because
you're an uncaring bad human being you
can't hold political conversation with
folks who are calling you evil just a
basic rule of political discussion so
here's my recommendation if you believe
in freedom if you believe in individual
rights if you believe the own your labor
if you believe you own your time if you
believe in the capacity if you have a
person across the table from you to have
a conversation then everybody needs to
embrace a free market and everybody
needs to embrace a free market of ideas
thanks so much happy to take a question
so now the fun part
as always as always I have a standing
rule if you disagree with me on any
matter under the Sun raise your hand you
go first
all right so how this is gonna work is
we're gonna have people go around the
back
and line up in a line along one side of
the aisle and then you'll come here
stand on the pink X I'll hold the
microphone for you and then you can ask
your one question okay yep we're ready
right on tickets
good how do you go for it oh I see a lot
of similarities between you and Jordan
Peterson what are your thoughts on the
Jordan Pederson Revolution I mean I love
Jordan I know professor Peterson
relatively well at this point and I
think he's doing an awful lot of good we
looked at each other the other day we
were having conversation on David
Reubens show and we looked at each other
and we said how is it that we both have
we found a huge market for saying things
like take responsibility for your own
life and tell the truth like how is this
a big market proposition and just shows
the radicalism of society right now that
this is considered an underground
subversive thought when you say you know
make good decisions and maybe you'll
have a better life so the fact that
Jordan says that the fact that I say
that I think that you know all credit to
Jordan I think that he's a really
interesting thinker a lot of I like his
lectures on religion our divisions are
largely about whether it's a matter of
religion being useful or religion being
true but we start from the same
fundamental premises about the value of
reason in a society that seems to have
lost its mind and so good for good for
Jordan I mean that interview of Kathy
Newman is everything right the interview
with him on BBC which I talked about on
my show is just spectacular because
being Kathy Newman is something that
everybody on the right has to go through
if you're if you're on the right the
media will take your views pretend that
those are not your views that instead
what you actually believe something vile
evil and nasty and then attribute those
views to you in front of you and Jordan
is one of the people who I've sort of
deemed the bartleby group for for fans
of Melville there's just a certain group
of people who just say no just I'm not
gonna do that and Jordan is one of those
people I think they're people on the
left by the way corner like this I think
Sam Harris is one of those people you
know somebody who I disagree with
strenuously on a lot of topics but when
he was on with Bill Maher and talking
about the the problems with
fundamentalist Islam and and Maher and
ben affleck went after him he basically
said no I'm not gonna do that and I
think that a society that's so skewed
that's simply saying no to basic
propositions that are false is now
popular it says more about our society
than it says about either Jordan or me
we're again we were looking at each
other and going are we the best that
society has to offer right now are these
the best are we the best thinkers
because if so we are so screwed
first of all I just wanted to say I'm a
huge fan of yours you've distracted me
from my own school because you're like
my new school watch your major I'm a
business administration major okay so
you may be learning more from me than I
mean I've learned more about like
capitalism and like how our system
actually works from you than like any
other I think I appreciate again but
yeah my question was what is your
opinion on labels in general so like
obviously there's a difference between
leftists and liberals yes do you think
it's important to like say like so
saying if you say I'm a conservative z'm
or I'm a conservative but yet you hold
somewhat dispute or some liberal views
do you think you should be saying like I
should be saying I'm a conservative
conservative I mean so I think that if I
were to make a fundamental distinction
between conservative thought and leftist
thought a conservative thought says that
when in conflict individual rights Trump
communal rights and leftist thought says
that when in conflict communal rights
Trump individual rights that's that's
the very shorthand very very shorthand
description of the ideologies you know
obviously there's some play in the
definitions if in the best of all
possible worlds we would all be able to
have just a giant list of our of our
issue resumes all the things we feel
about various issues and then we
wouldn't have to use labels but it's
useful shorthand so you know the truth
is that you can usually tell within 5
minutes of talking something least I can
whether they stand politically on the
spectrum and if you are conservative
because you believe in personal
responsibility and individual rights
that pre-exists government and a
government that was designed
specifically in order to protect those
rights not in order to provide you
positive I don't want to give you things
that belong to other people then you are
conservative even if you may stray on
various smaller issues I think thanks
mr. sparrow
thanks for coming it's a great honor to
listen to you speaking thank you coming
all the way up to Minnesota in the cold
so we all know your opinions that feels
about Donald Trump and why you chose not
to vote for him the election cycle I
guess my question is is there ever a
point where you think it's more
important to stop a radical leftist
ideology or candidate rather than
someone who adequately promulgates
conservative ideology and morals or I
guess in simpler words does the lesser
two are arguments for the lesser of two
evils argument ever hold water for you
so I think the lesser of Evil's argument
can hold water but you have to be
talking about something that is an
absolute fun incurable evil because
otherwise what you do is you fall into a
trap where every single election becomes
a lesser of two evils argument which is
basically what we've had for you know
since Reagan that's it's it's a serious
problem because all the parties have to
do is run somebody who's slightly less
crappy than the other party and then
we're all supposed to throw up our hands
and say Oh hallelujah we just saved the
country by voting for someone now this
is not a referendum on what President
Trump has done so far I like a lot of
what President Trump has done policy
wise I'm far more skeptical of president
from rhetorically I think that the
president has done continues to do
severe damage to the comedy in the
country and the possibility of building
a social fabric which I actually think
is a really important thing that said I
never said during the election cycle
that I didn't understand the lesser of
two bulls argument I just didn't think
it applied simply because I thought that
there was another long-term
consideration which was what happens if
for example Trump is so unpopular that
even he gives me some of the things I
want he blows out conservatism in 2018
Republicans lose Congress and in 2020
Kamala Harris is president with a
Democratic Congress right that was that
was a serious political consideration
also there are serious considerations
about the the views of young people that
are being shaped right now in electoral
politics if they look at President Trump
and they see him as the face of
conservatism is that too toxic and is
that going to be what people see of
conservatism now is the guy who during
the campaign pretend he didn't know what
the KKK was for example right that was
my that was my main critique of Trump as
a candidate now we're a year and a half
past his election and you know there's
new evidence so some of the evidence
suggests that he is actually governing
like a conservative I think a lot of
damage that I was afraid of him doing to
the country basically has already
occurred so the question is how much
more damage can you do to the country on
some of these levels I don't
no the answer is all that hi I think
that he's he's basically becoming what
I've said is he's he's now the strong
efficient markets theory right that all
the information is now priced in he
could he could legitimately shoot
someone on Fifth Avenue and no one's
opinion of him would change right he
could he could he could come out front
of the White House and strangle puppies
and everybody who likes him would say
that puppy absolutely deserved it and
everybody and everybody who dislikes him
would say that he does this on a routine
basis so it's so you know we'll have to
evaluate where we are in 2020 because
it's three years away but but in answer
your original question does it ever
apply yes it applies but I think that we
have to be very sparing about excuse
because it's very easy to move from
lesser of two evils argument to the end
justifies the means right those two
arguments are closely related and the
ends justifies the means argument is one
of the most dangerous argument a human
being can make if you lecture today I
had leaned toward it I'd lean toward it
because again I think that the the the
president has done a lot of things I
didn't think he was going to do and I
think that the system has constrained
him in ways that you know I were
unforeseen also I think again I think
most of the damage that he has done and
continues to do are has already been
done I think that if all the damage has
been done if the hole is already in the
boat I'm not sure that the situation is
bettered by a Democrat taking over with
the hole in the boat at this point
alright I'll preface my question by
saying that I admire your work for a
number of different reasons and perhaps
what I find most admire about you is
your strict sense of ethnic and
religious identity as a Jew on your Jew
is your Jewish background has clearly
played a significant role in in
influencing or shaping the political
social and cultural ideals and values
that you have as well as your support
for Israel as a nation-state so I'm
wondering then do you support the
classical definition of a nation as
being demographically and culturally
homogeneous like that of Israel similar
to the definition that American
forefathers generally upheld with
exceptions of course until the heart
seller Immigration Act in 1965 okay so
one I want to correct a
mischaracterization you said that I take
a lot of pride in my ethnic and
religious identity I take no pride in my
ethnic identity I take a lot of pride in
my religious identity so there are a lot
of people who have been born Jews who I
just don't care about really like no I'm
Chomsky was born Jewish she's a schmuck
like I I don't I don't care at all
Bernie Sanders born Jewish muck like I
don't know so so the point that I'm
making is that religious identity is a
different thing because that's a set of
ideas and values a religion is credo and
in the same way the American Declaration
of Independence is cradle so when it
comes to the definition of a nation I
would say that it is very important that
a nation have a Creed in common I'm not
particularly interested in having an
ethnicity in common when they say that
Israel for example is ethnically
homogeneous that's just not true Israel
is filled with Russian Jews and
Ethiopian Jews and Yemeni Jews my wife
is a Moroccan Jew so just because they
all have a religion in common doesn't
make them ethnically identical by any
stretch of the imagination
again there's no it's pretty hard to
find somebody who's more ethical
ethnically non identical than a Russian
Jew and an Ethiopian Jew so the reason
that I believe in Israel as a nation
state is because it's not for ethnic
reasons it's because of religious
observance reasons that Israel is a
place where the religion of Judaism can
thrive and be safe which i think is an
important
and I think the same thing is true in
the United States when it comes to the
Creed of the United States I think
America is a cradle country I think it's
what has made America great now that's
not to say that everybody who comes into
the country has an equal capacity to
assimilate that cream the assimilation
capacity of people I don't think has to
do much with ethnic identity I think it
does have to do with cultural identity I
think there are cultures that come into
the country people come from various
cultures who may not be as easily able
to assimilate because obviously that's
just the case I mean there are people
who come in and they already know
English there are people who come in and
they've already had a history with
Western democracy there are people who
come in and they've never seen a gay
person before and in their old country
gay people were came and killed so it's
important to recognize that cultures are
not the same thing as ethnicities and I
think it's a dangerous game to play when
we say that in that ethnicity means
culture when they clearly do not mean
anything of the sort hey Ben how are you
doing okay how are you I'm good
so unlike everyone else here I'm
actually a high school I represent I'm
the secretary of our young Americans for
freedom charter great and we fought
really hard to try to get you to come to
our school too but um they shut us down
every way they could I know I got to
keep this short but I wanted to ask you
what's the best way a secretary I can
reach out young young people who may not
know what conservativism is and how can
I inspire them to join the movement that
pretty much you lead well that's very
kind of you I'm not sure I lead it but
that's nice of you I think that as far
as how to get people to join the
movement people join movements because
they see flashpoints in culture right
the way the people most engaged I can
tell this from the way that people sort
of find my content most of the people
who listen to my show for example
originally engaged because they saw a
short video of me on YouTube or Facebook
talking about race or transgenderism or
something and then they use that as sort
of a gateway drug to actually see the
rest of what I was talking about and I
the same holds true for for politics in
most situations so the important thing
if you're pushing conservatism is to
find the flash points
this is true for everybody in politics
right left and center so it's also true
for conservatives and that is you find a
flash point that inherently supports
your position and then you say this is
why you need to get politically engaged
and you have to find out what the person
is really interested in not people and
not everybody is interested in the same
issues there are some people who are
very interested in the unborn there are
some people who are very interested in
gun rights I see the NRA hat are there a
bunch of people who are who are very
interested in economic Liberty now there
are a bunch of people who are
libertarian and just don't want the
government involved in their business
and so you have to sort of identify what
is it what what issue motivates somebody
as a general rule and then determine how
you make the approach politically on a
hot-button issue that's in the news
because that's the first people have to
be interested and what makes people
interested is those hot-button
flashpoints in politics it's not you
telling somebody to go out and read
Frederick Hayek it's not gonna happen
I'd be happy to do that after I think I
think we'll probably try and stick
around a bit do that
hi so let's say hypothetically there's a
young man here who is dating a young
woman who tends to lean very far left
so sorry before you go any further is
she is she present right now no she
isn't okay go Tecna be honest
I said how my do you have any advice for
how this young man might go about
exposing her to some new ideas without
the relationship crashing and barren
optimist so you my friend are making a
very large mistake
I'm sure she's wonderful I'm sure she's
supremely attractive I'm for all of
those things it depends what the
relationship is for are you in it for
marriage or like you actually have to
give me a like what's the end goal here
yeah marriage okay so if you're in it
for marriage then the number one thing
you must have in common with your spouse
is values you don't have interests come
after values but most people are
interested in lots of things there are
lots of interesting things in the world
liking the same movies liking the same
art virtually worthless what is
important is that you have the same
value system so politics are a
reflection of values now there are a lot
of people who never connect their
politics with their values so you have
to determine whether she's politically
left because this represent some core
values or just because she's been told a
bunch of slogans and now she repeats all
these slogans so when I first dated my
wife for example my wife thought of
herself as pro-choice and then the most
in the more that we discussed the issue
it became very clear to her that she was
actually pro-life and hadn't really
considered the issue in a serious way it
was just she was told on college campus
there was a good thing to be pro-choice
and so she said she was pro-choice and
the same thing was true of gun rights
for example she didn't know anything
about guns she'd been told guns were bad
and then when I explained gun rights to
her and when it turned out that her
father was a member of the military then
then she then she shifted a little bit
politics is the tip of the iceberg the
question is whether you're your
girlfriend's politics or this unnamed
person's girlfriend's politics our
are a floating bit of flotsam on the top
of the ocean or whether there's actually
a structural underpinning for what she's
thinking so you first have to determine
that if there is a structural
underpinning and if she really believes
this stuff on a strong level you're
really gonna have to think about whether
this is something you want to go through
for the next 80 years because it's
because when it comes time to raise your
kids I forget about you okay in my view
marriage is marriage not relationships
marriage is about bearing and rearing
children ideally I know my wife and I
have two children that is the end goal
of marriage that is the Telos of
marriage marriage was created so that we
could bear and raise our children and
that means that we have to have very
similar perspectives on how we want to
raise our kids now if you want to raise
your kid with traditional ideas of
virtue and decency and she wants to
raise your kids with traditional ideas
of multiculturalism for example then in
all cultures and all opinions being
equal all behavior being equal this is
gonna be a real conflict when it comes
time to parent your kids so you so you
have to ask yourself two questions one
is she movable and two if she's not
movable what is your end goal here
because you know there's lots of fun to
be had in life but when it comes time
for marriage marriage is as all the
married people in the room know marriage
is not the time for fun you know
marriage is Mara when it comes when it
comes time for marriage you know I've
not totally Durai love my wife and we
have a great marriage but see I know
she's watching
but it's invite but yeah when it comes
time for marriage it is deeply important
that you put values before all of the
other ancillary things if you have
values in common your marriage can
outlast anything if you don't have
values in common than the first break
and the things over
[Applause]
hey Ben hey I'm the founding chairman of
the young young America is for freedom
here on campus we're almost an official
group that you just have to recognize us
we have two people to go so that's good
news I'm also a convert from Ally
Annapolis to you which is pretty good
but my question you discovered virtue
congratulations yeah thank you
oneness you here on campus is renaming
buildings one of our buildings is named
Coffman Union it's after one of our
former presidents and he's been accused
of racism and anti-semitism in your
opinion should we apply today is values
to the Past in renaming monuments and
buildings so as a general rule I think
not this is I think that monuments the
names on buildings this is actually a
good educational opportunity I don't
like the phrase teachable moment but
they usually are so this idea that we're
going to chip off all of the names from
old buildings
I think that's foolish I think it's
actually very important as a country for
us to face up to the problems that we've
had in the past so over at Princeton
there's the Woodrow Wilson College over
Princeton and they were talking about
whether they're gonna chip his name off
the building I think Woodrow Wilson was
one of the worst presidents we ever had
I think what Earl Wilson was a terrible
human being but I think it would be
important to actually mention that he
was the president of Princeton and I
think it's important to say listen there
was a time in our history that racism
was not just a thing it was a dominant
thing there was a time in our history
where the First Amendment was not
protected there was a time in our
history where the where the Birth of a
Nation was screened in the White House
by this guy right the movie about the
the glories of the KKK it was screened
in the White House for Woodrow Wilson I
think all of that is useful and I think
all of that is good because if we don't
know our history number one we don't
know how far we've come and number two
it's a reminder of how things can go bad
if we revert back into our tribal nature
so if I don't know anything about the
person who you mentioned but if it turns
out that that person did a lot of
terrible things then I think it's
important to recognize the people are
people there's a mixed legacy usually
with a lot of these folks Thomas
Jefferson was one of the great thinkers
in human history and he held slaves and
he had six children by Sally Hemings you
know this is the that is a horrible evil
thing to do but that doesn't mean that
everything that he ever did was terrible
so I think that it's important that we
recognize what's
what we've done right in the past what
we've done wrong in the past and it's a
mistake to obliterate history I just
think it's I think it's and that's not
just my perspective that's the
perspective of Condoleezza Rice she said
the same thing and I think she's
absolutely correct hey Ben
howdy so I've been following you since
your Piers Morgan interview years back
that was awesome question so I've hear
you put a lot of emphasis on the free
market fixing for example like racism
and being self-regulatory a pure example
of this is if a business refuses
business to a minority a competing
business will pop up and steal a
business of folks who found the former
business immoral and that will run the
racist business out of business you're
blowing me here
all right so what the country is so
large is the United States couldn't
there still be enough niche market to
keep the original business afloat if
there is enough of a niche market to
keep it afloat does the government have
the responsibility to make it illegal to
refuse service based on the color of
someone's skin or do you see that as
government overreach setting bad
precedent so I think that there's
certainly niche markets for racism I
mean there's still people who sell
racist crap online and do just fine with
it but the question is are these people
who are going to thrive and also are we
willing to sacrifice your right to
freedom of association in order to crack
down on a few bad actors and this is
always the question when it comes to
rights it's the same question with gun
rights are we going to crack down on
hundreds of millions of 100 million gun
owners in the United States in order to
get the few bad actors are we willing to
crack down on freedom of association for
hundreds of millions of people in order
that we get a few bad actors
particularly when the market prevents
these people from becoming wildly
successful they are punished by the
market because if you're a racist you
can only cater to that niche as opposed
to being able to cater to a broader
possible audience the best example of
integration by the way through the free
market is Woolworths the the Woolworths
counter which was boycotted in 1960
before the Civil Rights Act by a bunch
of black students who walked in and they
said that they wanted to be served and
the restaurant said well by local law we
cannot serve you and they said well
we're just gonna sit here until you do
and pretty soon the entire world will
change changed segregation policy and
that's because there were a bunch of
people who said we're not going to shop
there anymore right the Montgomery bus
boycott is another example of this sort
of stuff working I think that that is is
effective I think it's actually more
effective now than it was then because
then you
he's bound by location right what if
there was no competing business they
could find a place to rent across the
street now everything's on line so you
can get anything online and all these
people who are walking into Christian
Baker's and demanding that they serve
their same-sex wedding first of all if
you can't find a gay Baker in the United
States I don't know where you live but
second of all but second of all there
are lots of cake making companies that
you can go online and just buy a cake
from them and if that Christian is
willing to lose the business well then
the Christian is willing to lose the
business it seems to me that's much
better cure for the problem of supposed
discrimination than saying that we are
going as a government to regulate who
you can and cannot serve as a client as
I point this out to Jimmy Kimmel who was
doing this one of my favorite punching
bags Jimmy Kimmel was was saying this
about exactly this case with the gay
bakers and I said well Jimmy I would
like for you to write me a comedy
routine about the nastiness and horrors
of Hillary Clinton Barack Obama and I
demand you do so right now right this is
your skillset how dare you use an IME
service just because I'm a conservative
you're gonna deny me service that's
discrimination how could you do such a
thing
the same principle that allows Jimmy
Kimmel to refuse me service allows the
the Christian couple to refuse to serve
the same-sex wedding and I'm I'm pretty
extreme when it comes to you know the
freedom of association I think that you
should be able to reject anybody from
your business you want to even if you're
a piece of crap and you reject people
you really shouldn't oh I'm happy to
debate Jimmy Kimmel anytime anywhere
anyway never know the night what's doing
hi how's it going so yeah I was a
socialist in eighth grade actually until
got cognitive dissonance watching your
Piers Morgan interview but since then
I'm a senior now in high school and I
found in the yeah chapter and are you
that's great so yeah I mean it would be
great if we could get a photo for
publicity be great for the city like I
say we'll try and get some photos
afterward but I see yeah
when you're arguing atheists in the end
of the argument of morality there's
almost always a concession that there's
no objective right or wrong as a
Christian or a religious person how can
we prove that there's an objective
morality without explicitly citing
religion all right so there's so there's
two basic approaches to morality both of
which rely on an unmoved mover one is
the more secular Greek approach and one
is the judeo-christian approach the
judeo-christian approach is revelation
right either in the Judaic version God
came down on a mountaintop and informed
people what was good and what was right
what was wrong and what we should do and
what we should not and in the and in the
Christian version Jesus came to earth
and gave a moral code
so there's revelation and then there's
and then there's the the Greek teleology
which essentially suggests that there's
an unmoved mover that caused the
universe to be the way that it's that it
is and in the very nature of the
universe itself you can discover rules
for living so this is the difference
between the Aristotelian good for
example and what you would consider just
moral good so you might say that
something happens and that's bad or
that's good what Aristotle would say is
it's not that something happens and it's
bad or good it's fit or unfit meaning
that certain things are created for
certain purposes so for example what
makes a what makes a shovel good is its
capacity to dig right so a good shovel
the way he is good is this way a good
shovel is a trouble that you can dig
with a good man is a man who can reason
right because what man is uniquely
created to do is reason one human being
sort as people as Justin Trudeau would
say are capable of doing is reasoning
and so the more you use your reason that
is what you were put on earth to do and
then you can derive a certain set of
rules people were meant to do justice
based on the nature of who people are
people were meant to get married and
have babies based on the nature of what
sex is right the these so you can derive
some rules from that now that was
basically I would say torn apart by a
lot of Enlightenment thinkers ranging
from
Hulme to Voltaire to to Spinoza but I
don't know that they sufficiently reject
that argument because then they go find
a moral system on their own or either
they find an arbitrary moral system
where they try to reconstruct a moral
system based on premises that are not
available in nature right they try to
set up universal principles like Cott
tries to do but that's a universal
principle Kahn came up with so it's
inherently subjective so you either if
you want an objective morality either
have to go to the nature of things and
try to derive from the nature of things
what you ought to do you have to connect
it isn't art in a way that David Hume
would not like or you have to go to
revelation and say here is what God
actually said to human beings and
instruct them to now the good news is
that the vast majority of things that
the Greeks thought were good are also
the same things that are thought good in
judeo-christian systems of thought which
is what Aquinas says what Maimonides
says is what Augustine says even even
though who's attempting to draw some
distinctions Christianity historically
speaking was maybe the first attempt to
actually Mel to the thought of Judaic
thought with with Greek thought which is
why the New Testament is written in
Greek as opposed to being written in
Aramaic or Hebrew which was the parlance
of the time so all of that is a very
long way in a historical way to say that
no one has yet come up with a system of
morality that is objectively verifiable
and that actually gives us all the
things we want outside of the history
that I just gave to you so this is what
I said to Sam here so Sam Harris comes
to a lot of the same moral conclusions
that I do right that we have individual
rights and that we as individual human
beings shouldn't hurt each other and
that we have the right to free speech
and that we have the right to property
now when I said to him is there's an
entire two three thousand year history
to get us to those rights right born out
of judeo-christian and Greek thought and
you're just taking the cherry off the
top and proclaiming that this is obvious
to everyone and clearly that's not the
case because for the vast majority of
people on earth for all of human time
that is not true and this has been our
main disagreement and again I think that
it's very difficult for for Sam or for
atheists generally to get to a moral
system that is not arbitrary maybe a
system that I agree with they may have
morality that I agree with but it's hard
for them to say this is objectively true
on any level without some appeal to
either the nature of things or some
appeal to say God himself
hey Ben so I'm definitely a left-leaning
student but I listen to your podcast
every day thank you for coming and thank
you for listening I appreciate it thank
you so my question is about race and
culture so while I agree with you that
when you look at white America it's
silly to say that the majority of white
Americans are actively trying to prevent
you from getting to where you want to be
I'm East Indian and I have definitely
experienced some racism but I never felt
as though it keeps Indians from
succeeding so I do think there's a
cultural component that supersedes the
color of your skin but I also think that
it's naive to say that it just so
happens that the same minority groups
that have been historically oppressed
happen to have cultures that are less
conducive to success I believe that
environment can create culture can you
acknowledge the historical reasonings
that led that these so-called
unsuccessful cultures and not put blame
on these minority groups I know that in
your heart I don't think you're a racist
person but in my in my opinion to blame
people for their failure for their
cultural failures without taking the
into consider an historical the history
in general conceals a lack of empathy
and sort of hints at racism okay so
I'll fight back on the last point that
that you know there's anything to do
with empathy or racism here but I fully
agree with you like 109 T percent like
100% I think the bad cultures are
generally the result of bad things that
have happened in the past or bad modes
of thought that have prevailed over time
so for example there's a great book by
Thomas ol called Black rednecks and
white liberals and that book essentially
suggests that a lot of the paths the
pathologies that exist about single
motherhood for example in the black
community or high rates of violence are
actually outgrowth of a slave and post
slave culture that was imposed by a
white society that didn't bother with
policing
that didn't in that didn't care about
inculcating morals or virtues in in
slaves obviously they actually actively
fought against it because they didn't
want that to happen and so there was an
active fight from a civil against
assimilation by white people that
created an underground culture that's
really bad and that existed in parts of
white America too it exists in
Appalachia so yes I think bad cultures
have nothing to do with race I don't
think that just because this is why I'm
I don't know why it borders on racism to
say the cultures are bad like some
cultures are bad some cultures are good
and that has nothing to do with race
charles murray wrote an entire book
called coming apart about pathologies
and white communities that that are
really destructive so bad cultures do
arise very often from historical
circumstances including historical
discrimination what i say is that today
there's nothing preventing an individual
from superseding the culture in which
you grew up and making good decisions
then the free country somebody's gonna
have to break this chain somebody's
gonna have to break this cycle and so am
I gonna I don't care if you want to if
you want to say that that the pathology
that exists in the black community black
intercity community of highest rates of
single mothers and violence for example
or lack of institutional wealth that
that is a result of historic racism I'm
fine with you saying that I don't have
any problem with that I'm not talking
about historical racism when I talk
about white privilege I'm talking about
right now the idea that there's a
superstructure of rules and laws that
are preventing you from succeeding or a
culture that is trying to keep you down
I don't think that's the case so the
question becomes if you are here let's
say let's say that on average the
culture in white America or with regard
to single motherhood to take an example
is is here right because there's less
single motherhood in the white community
than black community and in the black
community it's it's here because it's
70% single motherhood rate in the white
community it's 40% okay so the question
is before thanks to racism and thanks to
discrimination there was a cap on the
black community that was here and they
couldn't get past it okay now that the
ceilings been removed so what do you as
an individual black person do to change
your life and I don't think it's helpful
and in fact I think is actually quite
hurtful to spend an enormous amount of
time talking about the legacy of
discrimination and racism instead of
talking about what can you do right now
to fix your problem now this is a
general issue that I have in all of my
relationships my when my wife comes to
me and she says there's a problem in my
life before we even have the
conversation I say to her is this a
listening conversation or is this a you
want me to fix it conversation
and I think that when it comes to
politics there should be far fewer
listening conversations like I want you
to tell me about all the crap that's
happening I don't care I mean I care but
it doesn't but now the question is what
you're gonna do right that's a much more
important conversation because we only
have five minutes together is that five
minutes gonna be spent on all the
terrible things that happen which I
fully agree with that I would have
fought if I were there but I wasn't
right are we going to spend five minutes
talking about all the terrible things
that happen to Blacks and Jews and gays
and women and Hispanics in the United
States are we gonna talk about right now
what you can do to succeed because I
don't think that the rules are holding
you back so I've never ever at any point
suggested that there's not been historic
discrimination against black people or
even that current day poverty is at
least in part an outgrowth of that
historic discrimination what I have
suggested is that if you are using that
historic discrimination is a reason why
you are not as an individual human being
becoming more income mobile and not
making good decisions no one is making
the call for you right now as an
individual to get that girl pregnant and
that's that's the argument that I'm
making sure yeah so I guess like would
you like so would you have to admit
though that between different races and
different cultures there are there are
different levels of success and there's
definitely you would expect that
somebody who grows up with with with
unless with being able less to succeed
you you it's you would expect that that
would happen in certain in certain
communities in certain right that's my
tone about pathologies of culture yeah
for sure
I mean if you grow up in a worse
situation than somebody else you grew up
in a better situation of course you're
gonna grow up having obstacles that that
other person has to overcome but that
doesn't mean that that other person
number one victimized you right there's
no one in America today for example
who's enslaved a black person that I
know of or if they have maybe in jail
I'm sure that nobody in this room right
none of the young white people in this
room we're alive during the times of Jim
Crow so the question is do we take away
from the white people in this room to
rectify historic injustice is or do we
recognize that history is filled with
historic and justices and now we're
going to have to find a way to overcome
those obstacles together without
redistributing income for example now I
have called for movements for example
for for companies to go into inner
cities and make a deal with students in
inner cities and say to them listen you
get good grades and will pay for your
college and then you come after when you
work for us for three years to pay off
that debt I think there are things that
we can do in the private sector this is
why I think religious communities are so
important I'm not against charity I'm
not against us as individuals going out
and helping people what I am against is
the idea that the government can fix
this problem because the government
cannot fix historic inequity all the
government can do is set the rules at an
equal level equal law equal you know
equal judgment under law equal justice
under law is the only way that we're
ever going to approach anything that
looks like a fair Society there's no
such thing as a fair society where the
government plays God and give some to
others and takes from others would you
say that you basically we should take
other people who are not you know in a
press state they should they should wait
and wait for other people to pull
themselves up do you think that's how we
should solve or do you think there is
I'm reading in every culture in American
history every individual American
history who has succeeded has had a
combination of people who help them out
not in the government people who help
them out and their own capacity to
bootstrap it and when my
great-grandparents got here they were
dirt poor and didn't speak English a
great great grandparents got here
they're dirt poor and didn't speak
English this is true for virtually
everybody in the room right at some
point somebody came over here and they
were dirt poor and didn't speak English
and that doesn't mean that on a
generational level people are gonna go
from from zero to a hundred but it does
mean that we're gonna need to move in
the right direction as opposed to
sitting around and talking about
historic injustice all day because that
doesn't get anything done thanks so much
okay been very glad that you came here
appreciate it
listen to you a lot I'm attending one of
the health professional schools here at
the U and with the prerequisites of
course we're like anatomy physiology
biology and yet those are all offensive
in Terre yeah that seems to be the case
we've discussed quite a quite a bit
about transgenderism and whatnot even
more than say cardiovascular disease and
we've been having recess yeah I know
right
we've even had assignments where I would
get docked up or and not get the points
if you didn't say that you would let's
say even change their gender in the
medical profile to the gender that they
say which i think is just terrible
periodic yeah it's fully idiotic if it
says on your if it says on your profile
that you are a member of the sex to
which you do not belong then you are
going to get profiled medically wrong
certainly if you are having if you are
having lower stomach pain and it says on
your chart that you are a man we're
gonna be looking at indigestion if it
says you're a woman we're gonna be
looking at something else okay this is
idiotic
yeah so going out that I'm I guess you
were starting to discuss it I just
wanted to know what your opinion was on
sort of the implications of this not
only like a culturally significant issue
that you've talked about more invading
into more hardcore science institutions
especially considering your wife's a
doctor yeah she is as you may know yeah
so I think that I think it's egregious I
think that biology is biology is it's
amazing to me that people who proclaim
that there are scientists are so willing
to overlook basic biology and proclaim
that people who are fully biologically
male can magically become biologically
female we're not talking about people
who are intersex I always like when
people could debate this issue
immediately go to the margin marginal
issues where their actual is blurring of
the lines people who are intersex or
they have some genetic condition they've
Klinefelter syndrome or something right
that's not what we're talking about here
the actual argument of the transgender
civil rights movement is that people who
are fully male can actually become fully
female that is an obvious nonsense it's
obviously nonsense and again if you are
the the very idea that a doctor is
supposed to sit there and profile you
based on what you wish you were is so
insane and stupid and counterproductive
I mean if you're a transgender person
would you really want the doctor
profiling you based along the lines of
organs you don't have if you're if
you're a biological man do you want to
walk into a doctor and he's
and he's trying to figure out how to fix
your uterus you don't have one it's
ridiculous
okay the that you know that stuff is
just beyond the pale but it does
demonstrate the full scale insanity that
now predominates and again you know I've
had this argument a thousand times with
folks obviously and the use of politics
above science is obvious in everything
from what you're talking about
even the rewriting of the Diagnostic and
Statistical Manual the latest addition
which is completely a scientific based
on no statistical evidence and was
essentially a political decision to real
able gender dysphoria from a mental
illness or mental disorder was recalled
as mental disorder - it's not a mental
disorder at all it's just the depression
associated with it that's a mental
disorder well by that definition
schizophrenia isn't the mental disorder
it's only the depression and suicidality
they go along with it that are a mental
disorder you can literally do that with
any mental disorder so it's it's just
it's it's again for people who proclaim
that they care about science and facts
to say this kind of stuff is a
scientific and a factual
they've been so I've listened to a lot
of your content over the years so I
think I know most of your viewpoints on
things but one thing that I've never
heard you explicitly bring up and that
in my opinion is B is going to be coming
much more of an issue is the legislation
or lack thereof of artificial
intelligence could you expand on like
your thoughts on that because there have
been certain people who are calling for
significant legislation on that and
others that are vehement Lee opposing up
so as a libertarian I'm pretty opposed
to the idea of limiting the expansion
into artificial intelligence I think
that there may be some moral issues
involved well you know if once you get
to Black Mirror level where you're you
know quote-unquote you know creating
individual human beings with the
capacity to make decisions for example
and do these things have some form of
Human Rights
but I'm not sure that that's anywhere
around the corner right now these
artificial intelligence systems are you
know there are great certain things and
really bad at others so I'm I think
that's a bridge that we'll have to cross
when we come to it you don't have like I
don't think you have to foresee the
moral problems coming I think they will
just show up so I don't think we had to
first see the stem cell moral issue
coming up until it came up and then we
had to deal with it so preemptively
guarding against technology that we
haven't discovered yet is sort of
self-defeating because we can't predict
every piece of technology that's gonna
come down the pipe plus there's gonna be
a bunch of people who go around the law
anyway to develop such technology
particularly when you're talking about
computer technology and not just like it
takes a fair amount of resources to do
this in bio up in biology I'm not sure
that quite the same thing holds true
when you have the capacity for the
internet you know I'm I'm almost worried
about technology than a lot of other
folks I know there are a lot of people
who are worried that it's gonna kill
every job and that it's going to destroy
human beings as we know it and that
Skynet's gonna kill us all in all this
you know maybe maybe but so far that's
been said about every technological
development the history of mankind and
then we've created new types of jobs now
maybe I'm wrong maybe this is a
difference in kind maybe it turns out
the machines can think better than we do
and we can just turn everything over to
them well if that's the case then we're
gonna have a lot of leisure time won't
we because these machines
making good at things it will be good at
making things that we like we'll have
basically the Star Trek replicator and
at that point when all resources are no
longer scarce but plentiful then we can
sit around and watch Vikings games
[Applause]
mr. spiro thank you for coming out here
it's a song I listen to you I'm Bennett
and I am a junior in high school part of
the you have chapter that we have and
just a question for you kind of about
anything oh it's been two months since
the tax bill is passed and just asking
your perspective on you know only about
45 50 percent of American households pay
taxes and what is your perspective on
that when also not everyone has an
opinion on to where taxes should be
allocated when only about 50% of
households actually pay taxes and just
kind of your perspective on that so just
quick correction you mean income taxes
yeah federal income tax only about 50%
of American households pay federal
income tax virtually all household pay
some form of tax right pay sales tax so
they pay state tax or property tax are
that kind of stuff
so the answer is that it is bizarre to
me that you know we should give a lot of
credibility the opinion of people who
are not affected by a given policy
except that they get tax refunds from
the government for taxes that they are
not paying for example I always thought
that the argument that is being made by
Republicans on this that all people are
in the country are gonna get tax cuts I
thought the individual tax cut side was
actually kind of dumb because the people
who are paying tax in the country as I
mentioned in the speech are largely at
the upper end of the income bracket
they're not people who are at the lower
end of the income bracket so it's a
problem I mean I do think that as we
shift that burden more and more toward
the upper end of the income spectrum
it's gonna be very easy for the 70% of
the public that's paying not very much
tax to to put all the tax burden on the
other 30% of the public and there's
gonna come a point where people at the
upper end of the tax back from are sick
of that and they just start doing all
their business offshore which is one of
the reasons why I was in favor of the
tax cut not not even because it would
help make is it wouldn't I live in
California actually pay more taxes under
this tax bill but because I think that
it's important that we bring business
back from overseas and the only way to
do that is to make the tax rates
fiscally fiscally friendly to to people
who actually want to create jobs in the
country
hi mr. sparrow thank you for coming
tonight just want to start by saying I
was the chair of the College Republicans
here from 99 to 2000 former GOP staffer
and just want you know I'm on the team
but now that's sad I work for the
University now and you've always been a
champion for honest debate I'm aware of
both sides of the argument around you
being in st. Paul tonight with only one
date to work with it you were available
to be here you were given the largest
available room on campus and I'm just
wondering um your organizers of this
event helped select the room I have the
emails to back then huh
so isn't yaf threatening a First
Amendment lawsuit about your location
falling into the victim mentality that
identity politics is based on so I will
be honest with you I've been taking the
the information I'm getting I'm getting
from yif and from the students so I
assume they would tell a different story
than the one that you're telling because
that's the story didn't telling me if I
look at both sides of the issue and it
turns out that that's the case that you
guys basically just came to an agreement
this is the best available place that
that you couldn't find a bigger hall
that we actually needed a hundred cops
you know that all that is the case then
I'm more than happy to say that I think
that that would be victim mentality and
we shouldn't do that what I am seeing is
a pattern across the country of this
sort of stuff happening on a routine
basis specifically citing security needs
and I think that that's something we
have to take into account and that's
something that's dangerous like this is
this is not the first University where
members of the general public have been
you know there's a lot of universities
where members of the general public have
been barred there are a lot of
universities where they've shifted me to
other smaller sites there are lots of
universities where the canceled me out
right because of this and so if in this
situation that's not what's happening
I'm perfectly happy to retract my
critique of the university if the
university legitimately do the best that
it could and you have emails to back
that up
and all of that more than happy to say
that it's inappropriate for anyone to go
after you more than happy to do that but
there is a hecklers veto say and it's
partly it's also possible that you guys
didn't do anything wrong but what's
happening is that security situations
are becoming so complex because of the
left and because of what they're doing
that it's a bad situation for everybody
all around my suggestion is
you know again I'm from the outside all
I can see is that I walk through a room
downstairs with literally a hundred
police officers in it I don't know if
there are any protesters outside my
guess is probably not
if there are that are very few it's
called by my standards and so the and so
if you're going to staff a hundred
police officers it seems weird to me
that we can't do it at a hall that had
that holds 200 the 1200 people as
opposed to 500 but again as I say if you
show me the evidence I'm more than happy
to change my opinion on it all right
this will be the last question hey Ben
with the current Republican Congress
unable to pass much of the conservative
agenda such as repealing Obamacare
repealing daca and lowering the budget
do you think that there would be a
conservative movement in the future that
reduces the scope of government
dramatically or will conservatives have
to continue to sacrifice their larger
wants in order to get smaller victories
like the end of chain migration and I
hope you love the individual mandate I
mean I think that for the moment smaller
victories are basically what's in the
offing I think that in the future
circumstances change and we're in for
some pretty hard times and I'm talking
about particularly the deficit right now
people are just ignoring the fact that
the national debt is up to 21 trillion
dollars when Bill Clinton left office it
was five point two trillion dollars that
is a shocking multiplication and every
nation that has ever had this kind of
debt in in proportion to its GDP ends up
having to take some sort of austerity
measures so those austerity measures are
coming the only question is when they're
going to happen and Democrats aren't
going to put those in place so that
means that as circumstances change it's
up to us to stand out there with the
signs saying the end is near even when
people are saying things are booming and
growing all over the place it's one of
my chief critiques of the policy of the
Trump administration is that they've
been utterly uninterested in entitlement
reform which is I think the single most
important thing that the government
could actually do at this point and
Republicans are running away from it
headlong because they're afraid of
losing elections at a certain point
you're gonna have to you know you're
gonna have to sack up guys and actually
do something important as opposed to
passing tiny bits of legislation that
are supposed to please us well thanks so
much thank you for having me I really
appreciate it